(Epic Music)
- Hey, everyone! My name is Jesse,
and today I'm going to be testing out
which egg scrambles the best.
I have eggs from quails, chickens, ducks,
and Ade has even blessed me
with a mother fucking ostrich egg.
I'm going to scramble them all.
Try to keep it completely
the same and fair.
I'm going to feed it to three
egg-lovers in the office.
Let's get to the bottom of this,
and let's see which
egg scrambles the best.
Up first, I got these
cute little quail eggs.
I'm snipping them open
with these special scissors
that takes the top off
without crushing them.
I had to open 18 of
them just to make enough
to make one batch of scrambled egg.
I'm gonna season them up
with salt, some pepper,
and I'm going to cook all
these eggs in some butter
over medium heat.
No fancy shit this time, so
don't @ me in the comments.
The eggs look a little more yellow
than a typical chicken egg,
so I'm interested to see
if they taste any different
than a chicken egg.
Gonna serve it on top of toast.
Season it up with a little
bit more salt and pepper.
And that's it.
- Ooh! It's got some good coloration.
I see some white, some
yellow, some pepper.
- It looks like scrambled eggs.
Maybe a little darker.
There's not as much, like,
white yolky part.
(Surprised Moan)
Ooh, that is creamy!
- This is so soft. Oh my god.
I would totally put this in a
bacon, egg, and cheese sandwich.
It feels like, as if you
wouldn't need the cheese.
If this was just what was in the sandwich.
- It's like if a stick
of butter and an egg
just had an orgy.
It's really good!
- [Jesse] Up next, we have
good ol' chicken eggs.
And chances are, we all know
what scrambled chicken eggs
look and taste like.
So, instead, I'll take
this time to tell you
some chicken egg facts.
First, did you know that
chicken eggs can come in
green, blue, pink, brown, or white
depending on the chicken?
And did you know that the
average person in the U.S.
consumes over 275 eggs?
That's a fuck ton of eggs!
So, back to these eggs.
They look pretty typical.
So, I'll put them on toast.
I'll season them up with
some more salt and pepper.
And that's it.
- But this one is much more
yellow all the way around.
- Let's give it a try.
(Record Scratch)
- Ooh, it's gooey on the inside.
- This one's good, too. It
doesn't taste like a normal egg.
- It's bolder. It's confusing me.
It's, like, when you see
somebody with swagger
and you don't really know
what it is about them
that has swagger.
And you're like, "Damn,
that person's got swagger."
That's these scrambled
eggs. They've got swagger,
but I just don't know exactly what it is.
- It tastes like the perfect egg!
- [Jesse] Up next, we have duck eggs,
which are a bit larger than chicken eggs
and the shells are a bit thicker.
And they kind of feel papery.
And if you notice, the yolks
are larger than chicken's.
But the whites look super watery.
They almost have no color.
And it kind of feels mucusy
when I whisk them together.
So, I'm going to cook this
just like the other ones.
Just some butter, salt,
and pepper. Nothing fancy.
And I notice that they're
really, really pale in color.
So, I wonder if that means
they're gonna be less flavorful.
So, I'm gonna serve it up on some toast,
season with salt and pepper,
and there you have it.
Scrambled duck eggs.
- It looks, like, very desaturated.
Like, there's barely any color to it.
- Oh, wow! That's really smooth.
- You know the yolk flavor,
how it kind of tastes,
like, this chalky kind of
flavor? It's like that.
- Definitely don't judge
a book by its cover,
because this unsaturated
egg? It tastes amazing.
- [Jesse] So, here's what
you've all been waiting for.
We're gonna scramble some ostrich eggs.
Okay, and to secure it,
I'm gonna put it in a bowl in a bowl.
I'm gonna smack it to open it,
chip away the pieces,
and just kind of shake the egg up.
Because I don't know how else
it's supposed to get out of here.
So, I know this probably doesn't
look the most appetizing,
but maybe it tastes good.
I'm gonna season with a shit ton of salt,
a ton of black pepper,
because it's equivalent
to 24 chicken eggs.
And I'm gonna whisk it all together,
and just whisk and whisk
and whisk and whisk!
Because it took me forever
to get this all whisked.
Now, we're gonna cook it
some butter like the others,
and I'm only gonna pour a bit of this in.
Because nobody needs that
much scrambled ostrich eggs.
And it seemed to cook up pretty
similar to the other ones.
It's a bit looser, maybe more watery.
It kind of takes longer to cook, too.
So, we're gonna put this
straight on some toast,
season with more salt and pepper,
and here we have it!
Scrambled ostrich eggs.
- This is, like, the eggs
you get at a hotel buffet.
They may have come from a box,
they may have come from an egg.
Who knows!
- This definitely has a distinct look.
It's super yellow. Like,
it's very pigmented in color.
- Let's try it. Okay, here we go.
Oh, no.
- Ooh, I like this one.
- It just kind of feels
like if you took egg flavor
and, like, turned it up a notch.
- It has a lot of flavor,
I'm not gonna lie.
The flavor's good.
But the texture just doesn't
allow me to get past that.
It's, like, super soft.
- It just feels like a more
full-bodied egg experience.
- [Jesse] So, which
egg scrambles the best?
Let's find out!
- After tasting those four different eggs,
I will have to say my
favorite is the fourth.
It was the most different.
But most of all, the flavor was strongest.
I knew it! I knew it! I knew
it! I knew it! I knew it!
- After diving into the egg
world, I'm gonna have to say
that number one is the winner.
Because it just had the right
texture, the right flavor.
It was really good.
Quail eggs. Maybe I'll
start ordering quail eggs
at my local diner.
- Of the four eggs that
I tried, I would say
that my winner is...
Number one! The butter eggs,
because they tasted like
butter. And I love butter.
And I love eggs.
And it's like a perfect harmony together.
Quail eggs!
Well, if you like butter,
quails are where it's at.
- [Jesse] So, there you have it.
Quail eggs make the best scrambled eggs.
(Cheerful Music)
- Hey! Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- Subscribe here!
- That was my part.